Interesting for doom.
Just released a statement saying that you saw to asked him to snitch.
I know what's going on with the snitch and stuff.
I don't know.
They offered him a Alene more lenient sentence if he's willing to snitch and he
goes,
fuck you.
And John to the,
I guess John was like,
cool.
I don't know.
I don't either.
I that's what they're saying.
I don't need a John snitched.
Did you hear Johnston?
That's,
that's what the statement says.
But John's manager says that he didn't stay what statement from who?
The statements from him,
his manager skeptically at buffets.
Dude.
But no,
I'm not saying John.
Dude,
let's be very clear.
All I'm saying is he came out that statement and then uh,
he goes,
he didn't snitch and then I was like,
wait,
what are the big Novitsky was like,
no.
You said you're going to give us some info to help us out down the road with
other people.
So you know,
I don't what,
yeah,
you saw that to released an official statement went,
hold on,
wait a minute.
Because Malik came out and was like,
no,
we never agreed,
so we're going to snitch.
And then you saw it.
I was like,
well,
no,
remember really contract you sign.
Here's this section of the contract.
He said they would help them out in the future with other people.
I mean,
bring it up,
Jamie.
John John's world champion walking around wearing a wire.
Hey guys.
Hey,
can you just say work and got everyone else?
Anyone else just exhausted today are just so rich because your secret.
God,
anything Bro.
Why are you a full hoodie and sweatsuit in the sauna?
I don't.
You know,
I'm going to go out on a limb here.
I don't think that Jon cheated.
I don't need a,
you don't think you cheated?
No,
I don't know.
It's very murky water.
I might be wrong.
I don't think he cheated.
I think he took something that was tainted.
I think that's why they're only giving them a year off and I think,
look,
I'd set it on the pocket.
You have any skeptical hippo eyes about how it's shortened sentence.
It's ready to go right around New York.
No,
right around this ESPN deal.
Monkey says there was none,
but I keep saying that and everybody keeps running with it.
Substantial assistance doesn't necessarily mean it has to be on somebody else.
It could have been on himself.
What?
So go up to the part that you've sought us session.
That's what you sought a released that statement.
I said there are two avenues above,
above antidoping policy,
Lao for reduction of sanctions one individual and get a sanction reduction if he
or she provides information that results in Usada or another antidoping agency
bringing forward and anti-doping policy violation against other athletes or
support personnel and or two or reduction can be given if the information
results in a criminal or disciplinary body,
bringing forward a criminal offense against individuals.
Importantly,
if the athlete or support personnel fails to continue to cooperate and provide
credible substantial assistance,
you sought to,
we'll reinstate the original sanction,
that snitching where I come from,
but I don't know.
Now I don't think John snitched on anyone to get a shorter sentence.
We'll find out if Jackson guys are popping left and right all of a sudden.
But I don't think John did that.
I think that's just in there.
Maybe or,
or if,
I don't know.
We,
we do not know.
And I like to give Jon Jones the benefit of the doubt.
And I will say this,
if I'm a UFC fighter,
I am hiring malty to be my goddamn manager because what he's done with John,
what he did with,
um,
fricking all his guys,
you what he did with,
uh,
your boy Yoel Romero,
he goes to bat for them.
No one else is fucking with the golden snitch like Malika does.
Yeah.
And everyone else kind of just goes,
ah,
fuck.
We got busted man.
Not Maliqi man.
That dude's going to the end of the earth.
The fight for your freedom.
Yeah.
He,
and it seems to know him that well,
I don't know him as a person,
you know,
managers or managers,
but I'm saying if I'm the UFC,
because they can't negotiate your sponsorship,
it's Reebok.
So what can they really do your contract and now you've got to deal with you.
Sato who is a huge deal Mackey's this fucking dog right now that you want in
your back pocket.
And it's interesting that you saw that was just released.
Like they released a statement that they're changing their policies.
So say if you piss hot,
they don't.
And what's really interesting is Sean O'malley and right afterwards said,
Yo,
I pissed hot.
He said,
they don't want to announce people piss tot.
He goes,
I pissed hot.
let me tell you something.
They're going to check my supplements.
And uh,
we think we've got it nailed.
We think we know what it is.
But in the meantime,
this is why I was removed from this fight this weekend.
So they're not going announce it.
There's going to pull you from the card.
They're just going to pull you from the card.
That ain't right.
And they don't announce it.
I didn't write.
And then they go through the entire steps.
And then if you're exonerated,
you were never accused in the first place.
See the problem is,
is with,
is Sean O'malley,
whether whoever you are,
Travis Browne,
whoever name,
any fighter you want,
if you've ever been,
if it's even been hinted,
if you've ever had an issue,
um,
and you get that label,
nothing like people are just go,
he's on steroids.
They don't show big announcement going.
Sorry we didn't find anything my bat we saw,
Hey Josh Barnett.
So I had been out for 22 months my bat.
Right?
What the fuck man?
Right.
Give me some sort of compensation.
That's true also.
So it took you how long to figure this out.
I can't work during that time period.
And because of you I can't work and you made the mistake.
How are we going to make this?
Right?
Oh I bet you can go fight now.
That's insane.
Especially for Josh.
She's like 37.
He's not young or how about friends?
He's actually older than 37 Josh might be 40 yeah he's not,
he's long in the tooth.
He's been doing it for a hot minute.
Yeah,
I mean he was,
but think of your John Jones though,
Dude.
Right?
Let's say he lets say you're right and he didn't do anything,
nothing on purpose and it was some bullshit supplement and he's been dragged
through the mud up.
Rightfully so after hitting a woman pregnant,
all of that.
But with this,
that's a different thing.
That's a different thing with this,
you're like,
what the fuck man,
I could've fought Brock Lesnar.
I come doubled.
I can man live in dcs life.
But because of this I've been out,
I've been,
my name has been tarnished forever.
Yeah,
but there was something in his urine.
There was a substance and that substance is a performance enhancing substance.
The real question is did it come like there's a lot of people that got it from
supplements.
I mean this is happening all throughout sports,
but then there's people that say no,
they're saying that it happened from supplements,
but really that's just an excuse for what p for them getting pop.
That's what most people,
yeah,
the majority side with that.
The problem in John's situation is that he tested negative and then he tested
positive and he tested negative in a very short period of time,
which means that the amount that was in his system is a trace amount,
which is not anything that you could take that would impart performance
enhancing benefits.
They said it like having a drop of steroids and a huge vat of water.
It's like an a benefit.
Now some people and not me,
man,
I'm,
I'm with you.
I maybe he did take something that he wasn't supposed to,
but I don't think it helped his performance.
But um,
some people say,
oh well that he was micro dosing so it didn't get out of his system in time.
That's why it's such small trace amount.
But at the time,
if they would attest test and been a higher potency may be,
I don't think you can microdose this shit though.
I have no idea Joe.
I don't know.
But,
but listen,
they said he didn't do it.
Here's the shitty thing though.
Now dcs upset cause they're like,
hey DC,
we're going to strip you of one of your belts.
And John's going to fight for it,
but they haven't worked that out yet to try the Gustafson.
Jon Jones situation is still hasn't been resolved yet.
Dang.
We're gonna find out this weekend.
Do you think we see how the card,
yeah,
I think this weekend they'll have to announce they have to announce stuff
fucking month away,
man.